what is the answer the settlement
question well hmm since we're rival the
slap bang in the middle is negotiators
is what we call an off-the-record
conversation I mean the truth is there's
the simplest ways to decide the borders
once you decide to borders you decide
which settlements will go with the
Israeli staton which will be subject to
land swaps and that's something that
that will be done there's also then a
question for some people they may decide
to remain in their settlement but got
part of the state of Palestine this is
another solution to it because after all
as I say you've got twenty percent of
Israel are Arabs arab-israeli Israeli
Arabs right so it's you you could do
that too and and the the debate there is
at the moment which is why the peace
process is sort of teetering is that is
that people want the settlement activity
to stop for the process of negotiation
and the trouble with the whole concept
of settlements is that settlements is a
generic term covering many many
different things so you have got
settlements right let's say you take
this as the green line here you've got
settlements that I kind of here right
and here okay so they're on the
Palestinian side of the green line but
they're very close to Israel it can be
joined on to Jewish they can be Jewish
neighborhoods joined on to West
Jerusalem right and then you've got
settlements that come in here right oh
yeah here which is a lot tougher for the
Palestinians because they're worried
then is if you let these settlements
stay with Israel you're effectively you
you know you're you're it's a Swiss
cheese state it's not going to be
effective now you can deal with that by
asking or requiring these people to
leave which is what they did when they
got the settlers out of Gaza is remember
one of the huge problems in this whole
issue is the Israelis 7000 settlers out
of Gaza very very difficult thing to
have done but they did it so you can try
move people back or you can simply say
to people well that's
you know just as you've got Arab
villages in in Israel so you you'll have
jewish villagers in Palestine but you'll
you'll be a Palestinian citizen from
then on I mean there are a number of
different solutions in that but it's a
very very core and difficult question